welcome back to the think media podcast
Sean Cannell here and we are in our
YouTube Secret Series talking about the
perfect video recipe today's episode is
brought to you by
ytsecrets.com if you haven't picked up
the second edition of YouTube Secrets uh
more on that is in the show notes and we
could talk about that later but I'm
excited to talk about this fourth
ingredient of the perfect video recipe
now this recipe is not just some random
Theory it is a distilled process that
has come out of posting over 2 000
videos studying the best and most viral
videos on YouTube helping tens of
thousands of creators build YouTube
channels start YouTube channels
um and now I'm sharing it with you and
this fourth and great ingredient is
critical and most people mess up when it
comes to this step but let's recap
really quick and the first three
ingredients are in The Archives of the
think media podcast I highly recommend
watching this full four part series
and those will all be linked up in the
show notes as well so you can find those
directly but number one is the big idea
so before you even make your video it
doesn't matter how good the content is
if the topic is something people don't
care about it really doesn't matter how
much video editing time you take if it's
not actually the substance of the video
the topic the big idea is not something
that people want to watch interestingly
enough if your video editing isn't that
great or even your delivery isn't that
great but what you deliver is something
people want to watch the big idea well
then you actually can have a lot of
success when you talk about the right
thing at the right time and then inside
of the big idea is your thumbnail and
your title as well when you have the
right topic and the right title and the
right thumbnail at the right time that
is for the for a clear target audience
you can have a lot of success but that's
not enough that's the first ingredient
then you got to do the hook what's the
hook it's the first 10 30 or even 60
plus seconds it's the opening of the
video can you cut to the chase can you
keep the viewer watching can you open a
loop can you ask a question
that lets the person know that they're
in the right place and that also piques
their interest and makes them want to
watch until the end and then you got to
get into the content you want to be
brief be bright be fun and be done when
you're into the content use visuals use
props if you can use video editing that
makes the content more interesting trim
the fluff avoid rabbit Trails it's one
of my biggest challenges because I love
chasing rabbits and and they're always
there's so many of them there's so many
places to go keep it focused keep it
outlined have a structure to things but
then there's the transition that's the
fourth ingredient and my encouragement
to you and I'll break this down in just
a second is that as you're learning all
this it might feel a little bit
overwhelming and it might feel a little
bit like when you first started cooking
if you ever given that a try you know
like I love cooking for my family but by
no means is that a skill set of mine
I've burnt plenty of chicken I've
overcooked the the baked french fries
you know I've I've definitely messed up
a lot of steaks when I especially when I
try to cook them in a pan I'm trying to
to go medium rare and I forget that like
it still Cooks once you take it out of
the pan I've made a lot of mistakes but
what I've learned is you got to just
keep trying and if you follow the recipe
and you keep showing up in the kitchen
getting one percent better with every
try to cook that meal over time you
learn things I got a two-year-old now
and I make them scrambled eggs all the
time and and I learned that you don't
want to cook your scrambled eggs on the
10 out of 10 heat like that'll overcook
them it'll cook them too fast you get
that brown that burnt you know kind of
eggs you want those soft fluffy
perfectly cooked scrambled eggs that's
where I am now I'm I'm proud to announce
that I am a scrambled egg Master how
because I've done it every morning for
my entire two years of my child's life
more or less my wife texts me and she
goes can you go make his eggs and I know
that's a call from the wild to go get to
work and so my eggs have improved all
over time listen your videos will
improve stay in this thing keep posting
keep getting one percent better and
after you are making your better Big
Ideas having strong hooks improving your
content now is the transition what's the
transition all about here's the mistake
people make a lot of people
um as soon as they're finished
delivering the content they start to
land the plane and people are just going
to leave
uh you know this particular episode is a
little bit different because this is a
video podcast we put this on our video
podcast Channel we uh this is also
mainly consumed on audio and I want to
acknowledge you know everybody that's a
part of this community on Spotify and
Google and apple podcast and so even
what I'm doing in this very episode
because after I deliver the Four Points
I'm about to share with you you know I
have a little outro and I'll say goodbye
you don't want to really do that when it
comes to the best and most optimized
YouTube videos you just want to end and
you want to then transition to another
video the mistake people make is they
deliver their final point and then they
go well you know so that's it for the
content today
um as far as other things happening in
my life like maybe a few people are
gonna stick around for that but that's
going to be the drop off and something
powerful happens in the YouTube
algorithm when you can keep as high
audience retention viewers still
watching until the end of the video data
data and Studies have been done that if
you can have like 50 plus or 70 plus
audience retention at the end of your
video listen add a 10 minute video 7 out
of 10 people are literally watching till
that last second how do you see this
data if you've been posting YouTube
videos you can go in look at us go to
your YouTube analytics in your YouTube
Studio look at a specific video and you
can look at the audience retention curve
that audience retention curve shows how
long people are watching and you know I
was studying some of my YouTube shorts
recently
the YouTube shorts deliver some good
value but we added on this little clip
at the end where I go and hey it's
really fast too it is incredibly quick
and I just go uh thanks for watching
this video by the way you know this
benefit media video subscribe if you're
not subscribed it's very short something
like that and you can watch that ex as
soon as that starts Boom the little blue
line of audience retention curve drops
now you've got to make a decision maybe
you want to speak to the people who are
most committed and maybe I was talking
to my friend Erica kohlberg she said
there's some value to doing that because
otherwise people might just swipe
through in YouTube shorts or other
places you post Vertical videos and they
don't end up following you or
subscribing because you didn't give the
call to action but the principle you
need to know is that your goal is to
transition to another video not to tell
your life story not to give a thousand
call to actions at the end of the video
in a perfectly optimized YouTube video
not even a video podcast right and I'm
sure we could probably do a better job
optimizing these podcasts but these are
more conversational right and it
perfectly optimized perfect video recipe
viral video recipe you gotta just
transition finish the content boom
transition and people mistake people
make is they just start waffling around
hey hit like button hit the Subscribe
button you know click a couple links in
the description and by the way I might
post uh some more videos again soon or
not I don't know but it's sure been
great hanging out no no you gotta
transition so here's a couple tips
number one don't let the viewer know
your ending
a mistake people make when it comes to
the way they end their YouTube videos is
they finish the main content and it's
abundantly clear it's even it's the most
clear when you go so that's it for the
content and now as soon as you announce
that boom and you know you do the same
thing you've already been looking
through suggested videos of what video
do you want to watch next you've already
been like thinking about where you know
as soon as you know it's over you're
gonna bail anyways so it that just
reminds you to number one
you might as well cut the ending but
number two to avoid letting the viewer
know your ending here's how you do that
if I'm optimizing a YouTube video
perfectly and I deliver three tips I
might go and tip number three for
lighting your YouTube videos is to
choose the correct color temperature and
so you could go kind of a more Daylight
temperature or like a more Amber uh
temperature but here's the problem if
you don't set your white balance right
your video is still going to look wrong
in fact I did a video about that you
could click or tap the screen of how to
get your white balance perfect in every
single video click that right now and
I'll see you in the next video
so what I'd what I just do there that
example was me if I was doing a lighting
tutorial on think media I deliver the
final point I say I talk about different
color temperature and lighting and then
I say but but I agitate another problem
which is the second tip number one don't
let the viewer know your ending number
two agitate the next problem
so you know once you've got your color
temperature set the problem is if you
don't have your white balance set man
just not even gonna work so click or tap
the screen right now and I have a whole
video on that so I it's and then if
you're gonna say like the video and all
that kind of stuff do it after that call
to action so let's break it down don't
let the viewer know your ending so
whether you do daylight or Amber uh
lighting with your light kit you want to
make sure you set your white balance
right in fact I actually have a video on
that you can click or tap the screen
right now to go watch that video and if
you've enjoyed this video hit the like
button subscribe and I'll see you in the
next one
so you can give that call to action and
here's a key thing to understand when it
comes to the transition is YouTube end
cards
so YouTube allows you to link to another
video in your library or even on
somebody else's Channel
at the end of your video just for the
last 20 seconds what does that tell me
it tells me that's your outro of a
perfectly optimized YouTube video should
be Max 20 seconds
and the truth is I think 10 or less is
even better because 20 is a long time
and so notice that as soon as I say
click or tap the screen to watch another
video
that is when the end card would show up
and then from that time you would almost
want to have a stopwatch of what else
are you gonna say and you might be able
to you could say a lot you could say so
if you actually want to check out uh a
video I did about white balance you can
click or tap the screen there's three
seconds you know if you got value out of
this video uh hit like subscribe
there's three more seconds and remember
we're doing a giveaway and if you want
to join the giveaway check the links in
the description down below I appreciate
you so much I'll see you in the next one
there's another seven seconds we're not
even at 20. so you kind of want to
master the art of Being concise Landing
the plane quick and what Landing the
plane looks like is actually
transitioning to another plane as quick
as possible don't even land the plane
jump out of the plane like Tom Cruise a
mission impossible and try to get into
the next plane and you're trying you
know you're trying to keep the plane in
the air you're trying to keep the viewer
not just watching One video but
ultimately binging multiple videos going
to the next video in your library so
number one don't let the viewer know
your ending number two agitate the next
problem number three give a clear call
to action to click or tap the screen to
watch the next video why that language
click that's a mouse tap that's your
finger as people watch on smartphones
so we say click or tap the screen to
watch the next video to just give clear
language to let the viewer know because
sometimes people are also watching or
listening to your content
and they're doing something else like I
watch YouTube videos and I multitask but
when I hear that verbal instruction and
if my interest has been peaked because
you agitated the next video I watch you
agitate the next problem you just watch
this but she'd probably love this and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a problem
like and by the way if you love these
House tours click or tap the screen to
watch my series on it and by the way if
you enjoyed this video check out my skit
that I did with somebody else like
you're just you're pointing to the next
thing and giving a reason for people to
watch
so then you want to give a clear verbal
call to action and knowing that after
you upload your video you have to go
into your YouTube studio and connect
that next video using YouTube end cards
and then finally tip number four is that
doing a video series in my opinion is
better than just doing one-off solo
videos and what do I mean this one's
really important so stick around until
the end for this one
and that is if you're now asking Sean I
don't know what video to link to though
or Sean I don't know what video is even
relevant or actually Sean
there isn't even any relevant videos in
my library
well there then let's solved that
problem by architecting your content
creation strategy
so that there is relevant videos in your
library well how do you do that
that means that instead of just planning
your next single video you should
actually plan out your next five videos
or ten videos and they could all be
interconnected
in our online course called video record
Academy we go deep into this it's called
circular video virulosity it is creating
a network of connections around a series
of videos I'm even doing it in this
episode to a degree because we're
talking about the perfect video recipe
in four parts and so hopefully you're
getting value out of this transition tip
but to go deep on the other three the
links are in the description down below
um and then at the end of this video the
playlist the series
of these four episodes can be one of the
end cards or the only end card
so the only way the way I was able to do
that was I didn't just make a one-off
video about a mistake YouTubers made I
sat down and thought about a four-part
series what is a series you could do
that teaches something delivers
something it entertains in some way and
the story is spread out over multiple
episodes again your goal on YouTube is
not just to get somebody to watch one
video and watch it till the end if
you're doing the perfect video recipe
you want them to watch one video watch
until the end and then watch five to ten
to a hundred of your other videos it's
kind of like your goal in a restaurant
and having great food is not just to get
someone to find the restaurant come come
to the restaurant sit down eat the food
eat it to completion because it's good
but you want them to come back and tell
their friends so if the recipe is truly
perfect when it comes to the perfect
video recipe it's not just about having
one meal you want the food to be so
addictive that someone who wants to eat
it again and again and you watch your
YouTube content to be so interesting or
compelling and in some cases maybe they
become a lifelong fan or maybe they just
figure out how to completely renovate
their house and do a bunch of DIY
projects because they watch a particular
series of yours there's all kinds of
different viewers that may or may not
become a subscriber but are you giving
them the opportunity to watch a one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
part series with you the only way to
really do that is to start with the end
in mind and create the entire series
we call this the perfect video recipe
and it kind of reminds me of a story
that's been happening with my wife and I
once we recently subscribed to a food
service called hellofresh and now once a
week we get a box there's like this ice
stuff around it to keep the ingredients
all cold and fresh and there it comes
with some meat and it comes with some
vegetables and some spices and all the
ingredients and it comes with a card
that gives you all the steps for how to
make a delicious dish and what I love
about hellofresh is even though I'm a
novice cook now I feel like Anthony
Bourdain you know what I mean like I
just I I'm able to just open everything
up I follow the steps and when I'm done
I'm like man this food is delicious I am
absolutely amazing like you can just
call me Martha Stewart because I'm the
greatest of all time you know what I
mean and why it's actually not because
I'm that great it's because I follow the
recipe it's not because I actually know
much about cooking it's because it's
just a paint by number system that I
followed and I just focus on the steps
did what the steps were and at the end
result was that the food tastes amazing
but I do have a confession to make
there's been a few times when I still
mess it up there's been a few times when
you know I was reading the instructions
but I was like oh my gosh I didn't add
the lemon juice up front it's like
building Ikea furniture you get to the
end and you realize that like step
number three you did it wrong and you
have to deconstruct the entire dresser
no matter where you're starting with
following the steps and following the
recipe you're going to make mistakes
along the way and the reason I share
that with you is as we're completing
this four-part series is I want to
encourage you to just keep going to the
kitchen just keep showing up keep
showing up keep trying keep cooking and
when it comes to your YouTube videos
just keep pressing record keep keep
filming keep editing keep posting and
keep getting one percent better with
every upload see when you have the the
recipe and of course in the content
chapter in in the book YouTube secrets
we have 10 more ingredients in regards
to or rather spices underneath just
content alone because there's nuances
right there's as you you can do Basics
like uh you know grilled cheese sandwich
and then you can do like grilled cheese
sandwich on the Las Vegas Strip there's
like special you know spices on it
multiple different cheeses you could
take things to a whole nother level and
the same is true about YouTube keep it
simple at the start keep it salted In
and Out Burger nothing better right
pretty basic but they do it right and
then and you could get fancier as you go
but what I want to encourage you is if
you drop the food on the floor if you if
you botch it and overcooked the chicken
some of your videos your first videos
are gonna be your worst videos
some of the stuff you upload you're not
gonna probably be that proud of it but
you should be proud that you're showing
up and that you continue to show up and
what I want to encourage you is
subscribe to the think media podcast
stay connected whether on audio or video
because as you continue to study like we
don't just study so that we know
something we study so that we never
forget
and so when you keep you know learning
and you keep creating you keep showing
up to the kitchen of content creation
and when you keep learning as you go and
saying oh that makes more sense now or
now I understand that when I let that
simmer a little bit longer it works a
little bit better you start getting a
little better on camera you start
understanding your Cadence a little bit
better you start getting a little bit
better at uh video and video editing
what is the result my friends waiting
for you is that silver play button
waiting for you is those first a
thousand subscribers waiting for you is
that passive a hundred dollars a month a
thousand dollars a month ten thousand
dollars a month of income coming in
because of mastering the perfect video
recipe if you want to study this more
and go a little bit more in depth that
is one of the new chapters in the book
YouTube Secrets second edition's out now
ytsecrets.com is the URL there's all the
different versions that you could want
whether physical ebook or audiobook and
there's some other cool things uh with
the book launch of the second edition
that we're doing and so you can check
all that stuff out in the show notes and
if you got value out of this episode
rate and review the podcast or like it
on YouTube and I would love to uh hear
what you've liked best what was an aha
moment for you whether it was in our
four-part series on the perfect video
recipe whether it's on our two-part
series of the Seven Seas of YouTube
success all of that's in the archives
lots of free value for you to help you
go further faster and it would mean the
world to me if you also pick up the book
and leave a review on Amazon if you've
been getting value out of it my name is
Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube channel
and I can't wait to connect with you in
a future episode of the think media
podcast until then cheers and take care
foreign